what did you make up last night reg
again and touched upon it LeBron James
had been spectacular in these NBA Finals
just not enough and we've been talking
about this for the last two weeks the
Golden State Warriors
I don't you look at the playoffs for the
next three four or five years all these
guys are young in their prime with
finals experience with championships I
just don't know how any team is going to
be able to beat them unless another
super super team forms and then even
then I don't think that would be good
enough it was just a pleasure to watch
look if people want to knock Katie you
know I saw the the commercials of Nike
commercial the gravy train was just
funny
but you got to remember Katie has never
been a bad guy and it's almost like he
they're trying to make him out to be the
bad guy it was a business decision it
worked out he has a championship and
many more to come at the end of the day
that's what all the media and fans talk
about well how many rings does he have
they always want to compare everyone to
Russell and Jordan and those guys it's
all about rings personally what I have
done this route no but you're talking to
a guy for 18 years that has nothing to
show for it
no jewelry what I have gone that route
no but I 10 years into the league I see
where KD is I see where his head I get
it and I'm happy for him and he's going
to win many more championships on this
team because they are loaded and
powerful and they get it done at both
into the floor they are superbly coached
by Steve Kerr I'm happy for him if
anyone I'm happy for on the Warriors its
Steve Kerr because he has battled a lot
and I know how hard in time that he has
put in and to have this back injury I
really have felt for him and his family
and just by talking to him away from the
court it really hurt him and to have him
you saw the real tears in his eyes that
is the one guy I'm really happy for is
it good for the league that Golden State
is going to be great for the next couple
of years
nope it's going to be boring I'm going
to call it it's going to be it's going
to be terrible I mean they are head and
shoulders above everyone else they will
be teetering on 70 wins every year the
only thing that can trip up the Golden
State Warriors are the Warriors and
health if someone gets hurt but they're
also young and they all want to play and
they all work so hard people need to
understand how hard Katie Steph clay
dream on people they don't get to see
the practices these guys are vicious in
practice and they're only going to get
better they're all in their 20s so it it
will not be great for the league because
they are going to be destroying the
league now look I said they're going to
be teetering on 70 wins they'll probably
win 65 to 70
there'll be complacency games when they
just don't care but how are you going to
beat them in a seven-game series you
have to beat them four times and when
they have the best record in that
building with those fans with that
shooting with that defense lights out
unless another super team you know comes
out of nowhere which I don't I don't see
that happening all right so what's
Cleveland do in the offseason I don't
know what they can do and I look the
bran James was but he's to me he
solidified why for the last what ten
plus years he's been the best player on
the planet but it just wasn't enough JR
Smith showed up last night but that was
only one game you know you and I we
always talk about in playoff series
every game takes a new life it's a new
twist yes
but things are always formed in Game one
to me the theme was formed in this
series I really believe the Cavs gave
the Golden State Warriors way too much
respect and it came from LeBron James
talked about it's uphill climb
we're going to do our best there a you
know I've never gone to get the team
with this much firepower you can't have
your best player saying those things to
those guys in the locker room and
letting them read that and hear that
you've got to be talking like I don't
care who they are
let's go out and get these guys and they
showed that in game three which they
weren't able to close we thought would
happen in Game four with the blonds and
making threes but the theme of them
given them too much credit in Game one
we saw that in games one and two that
were blowouts you've got to have a
disdain for your opponent and they've
got that but they got it too late they
got any games three and four and they
showed a little bit of it in Game five
but it was it's I don't know what they
can do I don't know who they can get I
mean everyone's talking about Paul
George I hope he doesn't leave Indiana I
don't see him leaving Indiana but you
know the Lakers are a suitor obviously
you know they're talking about him in
Cleveland but they need help because
that was a gentlemen sweet really really
was a gentleman sweet
what about klay Thompson I guess he's
the guy that I want to keep an eye on on
on you know being satisfied there
because now he's moved down the totem
pole here and I know that you can go and
be the man some other place and get you
25 or 30 a night but you couldn't this
is your route to the Hall of Fame you're
going to play on this team and you're
going to have fun you're going to get
your 20 points you're going to play
great defense and you're going to win
titles you go to the Hall of Fame with
that not by being a man on the 76ers I
agree and it's one thing to be the man
on the team with nothing to show for it
you're talking to one so sit back enjoy
this ride I will say this if you're Bob
Meyers and the goal of a Warriors you
props can get a lot for klay Thompson
too but I mean he is such a big part
defensively he may not have shot the
ball great throughout these playoffs but
defensively I thought he did a great job
throughout the rounds guarding the best
perimeter guard on the opposing teams
keep everybody together reg
monetarily I don't know because you have
stuff coming up as well in KD I believe
in another half a year but but they're
going to be to 35 to 40 million dollar
guys a year you've got the TV revenue
which is going to help and plus you're
moving into their new building and I
believe three seasons from now and
that's going to be a cash cow and you
are the number one view team in the
world you are the Chicago Bulls now I
mean you you draw that type of attention
you know especially on the road so look
if you're the if you're the owners yeah
you got to write this gravy train why
break it up I felt for whatever reasons
the Bulls should have won eight in a row
I know Mike wanted to play baseball and
all but if he never would have retired
for that one and a half years Hakeem
Olajuwon Kenny Smith may not have titles
right yeah I mean it's safe to say that
I know they went out learned them but
you can make a case you could make a
case talking to Reggie joining us loan
from Turner Sports of course the Hall of
Famer what did the Celtics do with this
window of opportunity because it's not
completely open because Cleveland is
still the team to beat in the East but
Boston is going to add another younger
player when it feels like they need Paul
George as much as Cleveland does if not
more I think you really have to assess
the landscape of the talent of this
draft which I think it is a very good in
deep draft it's Gard heavy but you have
to assess the challenge do you build
with these 18 19 year olds going forward
knowing probably the window for
Cleveland with LeBron James I would say
what three to five years because LeBron
is still spectacular or do you package
that number one pick for some veteran to
try to go after that number one spot
with you yet this year but you weren't
able to finish it and really compete
with the Cleveland Cavaliers and LeBron
James if you're Danny Ainge you really
have to assess that folks obviously is
being rumored as that number one pick
you know you hear lawns of all you hear
Jackson from Kansas do you want to build
through the draft they also have a lot
of money they have caps space where they
can go out and probably you know get a
free agent or two so if you're a Boston
Celtics fan you're sitting in a great
position the question is how quickly do
you want to get to the mountaintop and
when the east because right now
everything as it's always been
goes through Cleveland and LeBron but
the window is shortening but if LeBron
is playing averaging a triple then they
do the average the triple-double in the
final they knew he averaged a
triple-double in a file and people are
knocking that are you serious
30 points in a triple-double are you
serious we were bringing this up
something that may never happen in our
lifetime is a rookie winning the Finals
MVP when you go back to Magic Johnson as
a rookie winning the Finals MVP I can't
imagine a rookie getting the opportunity
to go to a team that may go to the
finals and at age 18 or 19 even being
ready to do that as well so we were
wondering about that with with magic and
and would somebody be able to do that
the rookie would have to be a three or
four year letterman in college and then
go to one of those teams like a Boston
that's playoff ready and that's on the
verge of greatness I don't think in 18
or 19 the days of Magic Johnson are over
that was a different era and obviously
magic is a different type of bread
player I don't see a rookie being able
to carry a team let alone a playoff
series
I mean think of the play of Kevin Durant
think of the play of Steph Curry and
obviously we mentioned LeBron James in
the triple-double averaging during the
think of 18 or 19 year old being able to
do that let alone the regular season 82
games and then with the highest stakes
come playoff magic was 20 at the time
when I am being two years he played he
was two years at beyond state in micro
yeah you know I just don't see an 18
nineteen-year-old doing that to me I
think it will be a rookie that's played
three or four years in college and then
steps into our ready-made team but I
personally do not see that in today's
age you got a summer plans I do not I'm
gonna wait for the draft I'm going to
chill out I'm gonna get on my mountain
bike and I'm just going to enjoy it
that's it maybe come to Connecticut hang
out with no you're not coming here oh by
the way I did see your boy I went to the
premiere of cars three who's my band
Adam Sandler oh you did oh he is your
boy yes boom you're in all his movies
yeah I would assume you guys we got a
lot of I got a lot boys yes okay well
she told me to tell you hello and what's
the next project cuz I know he was
working on a project that you know you
were going to be in yes or not I'll be
sure to tell DP like Bob all right
Daniel Patrick do you want to be in a
movie I do not you do not I do not
though you are very good in all those
movies I might add I'm not trying to
stroke you at all but you are pretty
funny I don't know if you took acting
classes or not but you are pretty good
dude all right I gotta give you credit
I watched you when you tried to draw
those fouls and that challenge became a
good actor yes well then you should be
getting your Oscar very soon because I
did that probably we did you did you
were doing it before Duke basketball was
doing it that is true it's an art form
yes it is right but now you get
technical fouls there's nothing for that
now if there's no use for it now he's a
Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the third
thank you again for all the fun this
season it's amazing that it's it's done
but I love it thank you I always love
coming on here and Hooten it up with you
and the Dennis it's truly a pleasure of
mine that we've reconnected over these
years it was a great year again I don't
know who's going to challenge these guys
they're young and they're hungry Katie
wants what four or five and he has to
check he has a shot to get it to yeah he
does you know
I have a great summer but I'll be in
traffic or Danette thankfully the best
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the
third the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience